Oh, I can change. Oh, I can change. Oh, I can change. Oh, I can change your ways. Well, we'll see about that. We'll see if I can change your ways. This is Dr. Lara Schlesinger with the, I'm just kidding. This is Joel with the Tabruit Therapy Therapy Collective podcast. Anyone remember Dr. Lara? What happened to her? My mom used to always have that playing in the car. Man, she was mean. The people that email me and say that I'm too mean, listen to that one. Or the people who tell me that I'm not mean enough that I should be more fringe and more weird. Email or listen to that show.
哦，我可以改变。哦，我可以改变。哦，我可以改变。哦，我可以改变你的方式。好吧，我们走着瞧。我们看看我能不能改变你的方式。我是Lara Schlesinger博士，带着……我开玩笑的。我是Joel，来自Tabruit治疗集体播客。有人还记得Lara博士吗？她怎么了？我妈以前总是在车里放那个。天哪，她真刻薄。那些给我发邮件说我太刻薄的人，去听听那一期吧。或者那些说我不够刻薄，说我应该更前卫、更古怪的人，也去发邮件或听听那个节目。
She's very mean. It's been a long time. And if you're still subscribed to this podcast, thank you for waiting for the next season. I don't know if this is a new season, but what I've started to do is want to do some little updates when I'm thinking about something. I've learned that if I wait, I don't remember what I was thinking about. If you're 20, keep some notebooks because by the time we're pushing 40, hot damn, you'll wish that you had written those ideas down when you had the time to do it. This is called The Story Science Forgot,
她非常刻薄。已经过去很久了。如果你还订阅了这个播客，感谢你等待下一季。我不知道这算不算新一季，但我开始想要在思考某些事情时做一些小更新。我发现如果我等一等，我就不记得自己在想什么了。如果你20岁，记些笔记吧，因为当我们快到40岁时，该死，你会希望自己在有时间的时候把那些想法写下来。这期节目叫《故事科学遗忘了》，
why psychotherapy needs a narrative more than ever. So Joseph Campbell's the mythographer that I talk about a lot. he is sort of responsible for the Hollywood blockbuster indirectly. When Star Wars changed Hollywood, George Lucas was a UCLA, I think, a film student, and he read The Hero with a Thousand Faces, and that's Joseph Campbell's book. And then he said, yeah, there is this pattern to stories that are unconscious longs for, and we want to hear the story a certain way, and that's been repeated in mythology. trying to apply that structure to a movie and he did and um they've been doing that ever since
为什么心理治疗比以往任何时候都更需要叙事。Joseph Campbell是我经常谈到的神话学家。他间接促成了好莱坞大片的诞生。当《星球大战》改变好莱坞时，George Lucas当时是加州大学洛杉矶分校的电影系学生，他读了Joseph Campbell的书《千面英雄》。然后他说，是的，故事中确实存在一种潜意识渴望的模式，我们希望以某种方式听到故事，这在神话中被反复重现。他试图将这种结构应用到电影中，他做到了，嗯，从那以后他们一直都在这样做。
there's the joseph campbell reading room and um star wars sort of ended the weird third act problems of the 70s and the autour movement and resulted in something that looks like the marvel blockbuster now which is not really joseph campbell's fault i don't know if you would have liked those um but that's who he was he said that there was this monom myth um a lot of people are probably familiar with him i've mentioned him before i write about him a lot on the blog but um You know, he was not wrong. He identified these broad patterns in mythology that once you see, you can't really unsee, which is why he was effective.
有Joseph Campbell阅览室，嗯，《星球大战》某种程度上终结了70年代奇怪的第三幕问题和作者电影运动，并导致了现在看起来像漫威大片的东西，这其实不是Joseph Campbell的错，我不知道他是否会喜欢那些，但这就是他。他说存在一种“单一神话”，很多人可能熟悉他，我之前提到过他，我在博客上也经常写他，但嗯，你知道，他并没有错。他识别出了神话中这些广泛的模式，一旦你看到它们，就真的无法再忽视，这就是他有效的原因。
But he was also a little bit of a showman, which is why I think he ended up having the success that he did. Well, I mean that, and he also got pretty lucky with the time that he wrote it. And he wrote, Here With a Thousand Faces, this book about mythology in the 50s. And it didn't sell. And then he kept teaching and, you know, most professors that write like a book about the thing that they do professionally, like don't really expect to break the charts a lot of the time. And then all of a sudden his royalties jumped through the roof in the 60s. And he was like, what's going on, man? Like, why are you guys reading my books?
但他也有点像个表演者，这就是为什么我认为他最终取得了那样的成功。嗯，我是说，而且他在写那本书的时候运气也相当不错。他在50年代写了《千面英雄》这本关于神话的书。结果没卖出去。然后他继续教书，你知道，大多数写专业书籍的教授，通常并不指望能登上畅销榜。然后突然间，他在60年代的版税收入暴涨。他当时想，伙计，这是怎么回事？为什么你们在读我的书？
And the hippies started telling him because we're taking LSD and it's showing us mythology and stories and shamanism and your books, man. They're like academic and cool and you're square, but you're hip. and he was surprised so it sort of elevated him to this level and one I don't want to biography Campbell too much but like one of the things that he would do that um was a he did it a lot um especially when he was getting started he had a lot of the same talks he would kind of repackage which is fine you know stand-up comedian doesn't write a new set every day um but what he would do was like um he had this image of bare bones and one of his um they were from a cave they were millions of years old and I think two million to be precise or about that I don't know the
嬉皮士们开始告诉他，因为我们在服用LSD，它向我们展示了神话、故事和萨满教，还有你的书，伙计。它们既学术又酷，你很古板，但你又很时髦。他很惊讶，所以这在某种程度上将他提升到了这个水平。我不想过多地为Campbell写传记，但他做的一件事，嗯，他经常做，特别是在刚开始的时候，他有很多相同的演讲，他会进行重新包装，这没关系，你知道，脱口秀演员也不会每天写一套新段子。但他会做的是，嗯，他有一张熊骨头的图片，其中一张，它们来自一个洞穴，有几百万年的历史，我想精确地说是两百万年，或者差不多，我不知道那个
carbon date on the bear bone sorry but it was an extinct bear it's a cave bear one of the ones that you know once people started moving around they killed all the animals like I used to be like why are there lions and stuff in the Bible because there's not like you know there's not lions in these countries or these people well there used to be but they're gone used to be seals in Texas and panthers in Florida and all kinds of things but it was a you know I think a cave bear but an extinct bear and it's in this old tomb and it's buried sort of ritualistically and it's um you know leg bone i think one of the bones maybe a little arm bone i think it's a leg bone because the picture is pretty thick is shoved back through the mouth of the bear and it he would say
熊骨头的碳测定年代，抱歉，但那是一只灭绝的熊，是一只洞熊，你知道，一旦人类开始迁徙，他们就杀光了所有动物。我以前常想，为什么圣经里有狮子之类的东西？因为这些国家里并没有狮子。嗯，过去是有，但它们消失了。德克萨斯州过去有海豹，佛罗里达州有豹子，还有各种各样的东西。但那是一只，你知道，我想是洞熊，但是一只灭绝的熊，它在一个古老的墓穴里，被仪式性地埋葬，它的，你知道，腿骨，我想是其中一块骨头，也许是一块小臂骨，我想是腿骨，因为图片看起来很粗，被塞回了熊的嘴里，他会说
you know to these college students this shows that uh the circle of life was understood by the ancient man that hadn't even discovered writing hadn't even stopped evolving didn't even have modern brain like we have and they they buried these objects ritualistically which you know they did it was intentional and they shoved the mouth of the bear open it was eating of itself to give of itself to show that nature destroys itself in order to give new life and that we're in this process of cycles of creation and ancient people absolutely did believe that i mean Campbell's anthropology and archaeological record there about a lot of things we not know exactly what they thought about the Venus of Villendorf but we have a pretty good idea of the symbol
你知道，对这些大学生说，这表明古代人类已经理解了生命循环，他们甚至还没有发现文字，甚至还没有停止进化，甚至没有像我们这样现代的大脑，但他们仪式性地埋葬了这些物体，你知道，他们确实这样做了，这是故意的，他们把熊的嘴撑开，让它吃掉自己，从而奉献自己，以表明大自然为了赋予新生命而毁灭自身，我们正处于创造循环的过程中，古代人绝对相信这一点。我是说Campbell的人类学和考古记录，关于很多事情，我们可能不知道他们对维伦多夫的维纳斯到底是怎么想的，但我们对这些符号所指向的符号、力量有相当好的了解。
symbols, the forces that these symbols were pointing to. And the bear bones, you know, he would use to illustrate this. But here, like, here's the thing. They're two million-year-old bones. Like, the bone could have just fallen into the bear's mouth. They could have thrown it in the hole. It may not mean that, you know, and he would talk in this way that was very deterministic, but it was also compelling. And he told a story. And it was a story that resonated so deeply with something in the human psyche, they became this, you know, invisible architecture of an industry now and made him one of the most popular speakers in the world at the time. He died pretty young.
而熊骨头，你知道，他会用它来说明这一点。但这里，事情是这样的。那是两百万年前的骨头。骨头可能只是掉进了熊的嘴里。他们可能只是把它扔进了洞里。这可能并不意味着什么，你知道，他说话的方式非常宿命论，但也很有说服力。他讲了一个故事。这是一个与人类心灵深处产生强烈共鸣的故事，它们现在成为了一个行业的隐形架构，并使他成为当时世界上最受欢迎的演讲者之一。他去世时还很年轻。
I wonder what would have happened to Campbell sometimes because a lot of the male Jungians tend to kind of go mad. They don't age well. They get kind of weird by the end of their life. And I worry about that with myself. I talk about James Hellman a lot. but I'm digressing here. So, you know, Campbell didn't know that he was objectively right about those bare bones,
有时我好奇Campbell会发生什么，因为很多男性荣格派学者往往会变得疯狂。他们老得并不优雅。他们在生命尽头变得有点古怪。我为自己担心这一点。我经常谈论James Hillman。但我离题了。所以，你知道，Campbell并不知道他关于那些熊骨头的说法在客观上是正确的，
but he was pointing at something that was real about humans make meaning. So it didn't really matter if the person who put those bones in the ground two million years ago had the exact same thought process that Campbell was saying because he was using it as a piece of evidence to kind of gesture at a story and a bigger truth than whatever this caveman was thinking when they put that there. And that story that he told about making meaning was more powerful than any peer-reviewed paper. And it connected a lot of people to depth psychology in a way that probably let depth psychology
但他指出了关于人类创造意义的真实之处。所以，两百万年前把那些骨头放进地里的人是否有着和Campbell所说的一模一样的思维过程并不重要，因为他把它当作证据，用来指向一个故事，一个比这个穴居人在放骨头时所想的任何事情都更大的真理。他讲述的关于创造意义的故事比任何同行评审的论文都更有力量。它以一种方式将许多人与深度心理学联系起来，这种方式可能让深度心理学
survive in a way that it wouldn't have if it hadn't overlapped with the culture because there were all these fresh recruits, the people that are obsessive, that they watch Star Wars, and then they want to learn about the mythology that Star Wars was based on, and then they want to look at the people that Campbell's pointing at, and they come across people like Jung and other mythographers and anthropologists that are in the up psychology space. Campbell was not terribly honest, I think, about how much he took from Jung. He really could have written the same book and been a Jungian analyst, but that wasn't his bag. He, you know, he mentions Jung a little bit, but he criticized this Freud. You know,
以一种如果没有与文化重叠就不会有的方式生存下来，因为有所有这些新兵，那些痴迷的人，他们看《星球大战》，然后他们想了解《星球大战》所基于的神话，然后他们想看看Campbell所指的人，他们遇到了像荣格以及深度心理学领域的其他神话学家和人类学家。我认为Campbell在谈到他从荣格那里借鉴了多少时并不是特别诚实。他完全可以写出同样的书并成为一名荣格分析师，但那不是他的菜。他，你知道，他稍微提到了荣格，但他批评了弗洛伊德。你知道，
I've said on the weird history of psychotherapy series, he says that Freud was sitting while, or fishing while he was sitting on a whale. And then he read Freud every year. And then eventually he did clear reading Freud because he wasn't going to be. get anything out of it anymore. But every time he read Jung, it changed. That's the most credit that I've ever found across all of his writing that he gave him, that Jung, he never read him the same. And no matter where he was with his discoveries, and no matter how many times he'd read it, he got something new out of Jung. But he didn't give a lot of credit to the hero's journey, really kind of being this deconstruction of a depth psychology process, you know, as much
我在心理治疗的怪异历史系列中说过，他说弗洛伊德是在鲸鱼背上钓鱼。然后他每年都读弗洛伊德。最后他确实不再读弗洛伊德了，因为他从中得不到任何东西了。但每次他读荣格，情况就变了。这是我在他所有著作中发现的他给予荣格的最高评价，即荣格，他从来没有以同样的方式读过他。无论他的发现处于什么阶段，无论他读了多少遍，他都能从荣格那里得到新的东西。但他并没有给英雄之旅太多的功劳，它实际上是一种深度心理学过程的解构，你知道，不像
as some people would like, but, you know, whatever. I don't want to legate feuds from the 1960s. when I first went into the field of psychotherapy, I had this kind of fantasy because I read a lot of Campbell in these things in high school. I wrote my college entry essay actually on him. And I was trying to find this place like Berkeley in the 70s and I wanted to immerse myself in the grand conversation between psychology and mythology and anthropology and philosophy and trauma and integrated care. And I imagine something like the Eastland Institute in the 1970s, you know, because I had read about it and I didn't know as a high schooler that the world was the way that it was now. And, you know, Fritz Perl's developed Gestalt therapy and the, you know, so much stuff.
有些人希望的那样，但，你知道，随它去吧。我不想去争论60年代的恩怨。当我第一次进入心理治疗领域时，我有这种幻想，因为我在高中时读了很多Campbell的东西。我实际上写了关于他的大学入学论文。我试图找到像70年代伯克利那样的地方，我想让自己沉浸在心理学、神话学、人类学、哲学、创伤和综合护理之间的宏大对话中。我想象着像70年代的伊斯兰研究所那样的地方，你知道，因为我读过关于它的东西，作为一个高中生，我不知道世界现在是这个样子。而且，你知道，Fritz Perls发展了格式塔疗法，还有，你知道，太多的东西。
And I don't want to get lost in the history here. But these researchers and clinicians and mystics, they sat together in Hot Springs. And they argued about the nature of consciousness at Eastland. And, you know, those places barely exist anymore. Institutes, which is one of the reason why I founded Taproot Therapy Collective as an institute that they probably would have been a lot wealthier. if I had gone in a direction where I was not running a socialist collective, but when you do that, you get the best people because you don't make any money because you pay the money to them, and you're bundling the cost of services, and it lets you have the luxury of getting the brightest
我不想在这里迷失在历史中。但这些研究人员、临床医生和神秘主义者，他们坐在温泉里。他们在伊斯兰研究所争论意识的本质。而且，你知道，那些地方几乎不存在了。研究所，这也是我创立Taproot治疗集体的原因，作为一个研究所，如果我走的方向不是经营一个社会主义集体，他们可能会富有得多，但当你这样做时，你会得到最好的人，因为你赚不到钱，因为你把钱付给了他们，你捆绑了服务成本，这让你有奢侈的条件把最聪明的人
people in one place so that you can develop these new things. And when I first came out of school, you know, before I found a taproot, when I was, you know, trying to find a place to work or find a professional identity, I found this competitive model that psychology had turned into that was built on H indexes and impact factors. If you're not familiar with those, that's how you give value to your work. You know, the H index tells you how much somebody has cited your paper. And the impact factor says how many people actually read this research journal. Yeah, you've got to publish, but is this journal really worth it, damn?
聚集在一个地方，这样你就可以开发这些新东西。当我刚从学校出来时，你知道，在我创立Taproot之前，当我，你知道，试图找个地方工作或寻找职业认同感时，我发现了心理学已经变成的那种竞争模式，它是建立在H指数和影响因子之上的。如果你不熟悉这些，这就是你赋予工作价值的方式。你知道，H指数告诉你某人引用了你的论文多少次。而影响因子说明有多少人真正阅读了这本研究期刊。是的，你必须发表，但这本期刊真的值得吗，该死？
And that people were chasing those numbers in a way that had kind of ripped the profession a part. And that's always been a part of psychology. I mean, a lot of people are like, well, I went to school in the 70s, and we still had that. It was a big book in the library. You flipped through, and it still told you, you know, and that's true. These things are remarkably different now. I read about that a little bit. I, you know, I found these academic departments had been siloed into these narrow specializations. You weren't allowed to connect the dots anymore. You know, people are like, that's fine, but you don't have a PhD in anthropology. so you can't talk about that.
人们以一种撕裂了整个行业的方式追逐这些数字。这一直是心理学的一部分。我是说，很多人说，嗯，我在70年代上学，我们当时也有这个。图书馆里有一本大书。你翻阅它，它仍然告诉你，你知道，这是真的。这些事情现在非常不同了。我读过一点关于那个的内容。我，你知道，我发现这些学术部门被孤立成这些狭窄的专业。你不再被允许连接这些点。你知道，人们会说，那很好，但你没有人类学博士学位，所以你不能谈论那个。
And I'm like, well, I mean, we're all kind of studying psychology. Like, aren't we? You know, you're, and, you know, all these departments defended their territory, these boundaries, and they didn't want other disciplines to merge. I mean, people like David Tacey, I think, is probably one of the better academics working in the time that he was working. You know, he was a threat because he knew too much about too many things. And academia wants you to know a whole lot about one thing.
我说，嗯，我是说，我们都在研究心理学。不是吗？你知道，你，而且，你知道，所有这些部门都在捍卫他们的领地，这些界限，他们不想让其他学科合并。我是说，像David Tacey这样的人，我认为可能是他工作时期最好的学者之一。你知道，他是一个威胁，因为他知道太多关于太多事情的东西。而学术界希望你对一件事知道得非常多。
But I think that that is sort of a way, I mean, maybe sort of intentionally, maybe sort of unintentionally of keeping the profession blind. Because everybody's touching one part of the elephant. They can't see the whole thing. And so, you know, what we have instead now are these specialists who don't read outside of their subspecialty. Even in psychology, people will say, well, I can't say anything about marriage and family counseling because I wasn't trained in that. And it's like, well, I mean, you don't want to say you're an expert, but like, you know something. And there's a defensiveness.
但我认为这是一种方式，我是说，也许是有意的，也许是无意的，让这个行业保持盲目。因为每个人都在摸大象的一部分。他们看不到整体。所以，你知道，我们现在拥有的是这些不阅读其子专业之外内容的专家。即使在心理学领域，人们也会说，嗯，我不能对婚姻和家庭咨询发表任何意见，因为我没有受过那方面的训练。这就像，嗯，我是说，你不想说你是专家，但像，你知道一些东西。而且有一种防御心理。
And this is not just, you know, like academic inconvenience. It's a catastrophe for the human sciences and for the actual treatment of trauma patients. I mean, I think this is one of the best cases for why something like Freud that's not terribly useful and not terribly correct stuck around. You know, psychoanalysis is still practiced in New York pretty widely. That may be one of the only places. But like it's not because psychoanalysis was rigorously validated in these controlled trials. It's because, you know, John Horgan says this, you know, that I think he says like old paradigms die, but only when we have better paradigms to replace them. And science never provided a better story than psychoanalysis.
这不仅仅是，你知道，像学术上的不便。这对人类科学和创伤患者的实际治疗来说是一场灾难。我是说，我认为这是为什么像弗洛伊德这样不是特别有用且不是特别正确的理论能够留存下来的最好案例之一。你知道，精神分析在纽约仍然被广泛实践。那可能是仅有的几个地方之一。但这并不是因为精神分析在这些对照试验中得到了严格验证。这是因为，你知道，John Horgan说过这个，你知道，我想他说的是旧范式会消亡，但只有当我们有更好的范式来取代它们时。而科学从未提供比精神分析更好的故事。
And because science never provided a better story, the story that existed stuck around because a story can only be replaced by another story, not a number. And the biomedical model has failed to provide us a better story. The biomedical model of psychology. If you're studying cancer, my arguments against the way that we do evidence-based practice are not relevant to you. If you're studying quantum physics at CERN, like my friend who hopefully comes on the podcast this season, you know, that is a hard science. What I'm describing is people trying to make psychologists,
因为科学从未提供更好的故事，现有的故事就留了下来，因为一个故事只能被另一个故事取代，而不是一个数字。而生物医学模型未能为我们提供一个更好的故事。心理学的生物医学模型。如果你在研究癌症，我反对我们进行循证实践方式的论点与你无关。如果你在研究CERN的量子物理学，像我希望本季来参加播客的朋友一样，你知道，那是硬科学。我所描述的是人们试图让心理学，
which is a soft science, a hard science, pretending that it is. But then worse, pretending that it is only when it suits them, only as a cudgel, not where it could be innovative and grow. And it's that double standard that, you know, it takes 15 minutes for most people. You know, that's a long appointment with the psychiatrist before you get put on medication. You know, this person is, and I don't have a problem with medication, I think some people should be on it. and I think some people are ever medicated. You know, I'm a metal ground.
这是一种软科学，变成硬科学，假装它是。但更糟糕的是，假装它是，只有在适合他们的时候，只有作为一种棍棒，而不是在它可以创新和成长的地方。正是这种双重标准，你知道，大多数人需要15分钟。你知道，在服用药物之前，那是与精神科医生的漫长预约。你知道，这个人是，我并不反对药物，我认为有些人应该服用它。而且我认为有些人被过度用药了。你知道，我是一个中间派。
People get angry because they say I'm anti-science because I said something about medication and other people get angry because they say you can heal yourself with crystals and you don't need antidepressants. I'm not in either camp. Feel free to continue to not like me. Don't email me, please.
人们很生气，因为他们说我反科学，因为我说了关于药物的事情，而其他人很生气，因为他们说你可以用晶体治愈自己，你不需要抗抑郁药。我不在任何阵营。请随意继续不喜欢我。请不要给我发邮件。
But, you know, this doctor now looks at a checklist and they ask about your appetite and they ask about your energy levels and then they treat symptoms like check engine lights on this dashboard, and they prescribe a pill. and then they send you out. And that is not the way that psychiatry used to be practiced. And psychiatrists also used to do therapy.
但是，你知道，这位医生现在看着一张清单，他们询问你的食欲和能量水平，然后他们像仪表盘上的检查引擎灯一样治疗症状，然后他们开药。然后他们把你打发走。这并不是精神病学过去被实践的方式。而且精神科医生过去也做治疗。
The people that you're reading about, Irvin Yalom, you know, that got a lot of people into therapy. He was a lot of people's gateway drug. He was a psychiatrist that actually did therapy. They don't anymore. I was watching the show Evil recently, and the psychiatrist is like sitting there and doing therapy and prescribing a medication. It's like, how often does that happen?
你正在读的那些人，Irvin Yalom，你知道，他让很多人进入了治疗。他是很多人的入门毒品。他是一位真正做治疗的精神科医生。他们现在不做了。我最近在看《邪恶》这部剧，精神科医生坐在那里做治疗并开药。这就像，这种情况多久发生一次？
And how often can this supposedly poor character afford, you know, an hour, two hours of psychotherapy from a psychiatrist a week? You know, how often could she, how often would she afforded if it was a social worker like myself doing the therapy? You know, it's expensive. You know, if you find a psychiatrist in Birmingham who's still doing therapy, they're probably doing Ericksonian hypnosis or something. And they're probably pushing 80 at this point. Those are the only ones that I know that are doing it. And, you know, the result of that is that we started to move to these checklists and inventories and objective assessments that we pretended could do intuition and thinking and subjective science for us. And that hasn't worked out because the more evidence-based, and I don't really think the way we practice psychology in America is evidence-based, but the way that what we call,
而且这个所谓的贫穷角色多久能负担得起，你知道，每周从精神科医生那里进行一两个小时的心理治疗？你知道，如果是一个像我这样的社会工作者在做治疗，她多久能负担得起？你知道，这很贵。你知道，如果你在伯明翰找到一位还在做治疗的精神科医生，他们可能在做艾瑞克森催眠之类的东西。而且他们此时可能快80岁了。这些是我知道的唯一还在做的人。而且，你知道，结果就是我们开始转向这些清单、量表和客观评估，我们假装它们可以为我们进行直觉、思考和主观科学。但这并没有奏效，因为越是循证，而且我真的不认为我们在美国实践心理学的方式是循证的，但我们所称的，
basis of evidence. As we have moved closer to the way we have defined the basis of evidence to a more evidence-based psychology, our outcomes have gotten worse. So why? Like if it really is an evidence-based model, why when you are doing it, is it not working as well as it worked before? You look at something like the Stard-Y study. I'm not going to talk about the Stardee study that much. You can Google it. You can look at one of my articles, many of my articles. But, you know, that was a study that it was a meta study. So it was like a pilot study, and then all of this other data was drawn from it. And the way they stack these things, if the initial thing was not right,
证据基础。随着我们越来越接近我们将证据基础定义为一种更循证的心理学的方式，我们的结果反而变差了。所以为什么？如果它真的是一个循证模型，为什么当你这样做时，它的效果不如以前好？你看看像Stard-Y研究这样的东西。我不会谈论Stardee研究太多。你可以谷歌一下。你可以看看我的一篇文章，我的很多文章。但是，你知道，那是一项研究，它是一项元研究。所以它就像一项试点研究，然后所有这些其他数据都是从中提取的。他们堆叠这些东西的方式，如果最初的东西是不对的，
then the billion dollars of research he spent on other studies following the initial study, all are bunk. And it guided psychiatry in this country for 10 years. It was seen as the most comprehensive thing. And then it came out because there were a couple critics. that it was complete bullshit, that they were covering up in the thing that mugwort or St. John's ward or something had like a better outcome than Welbutrin. The idea that you could just do CBT and then send somebody to a psychiatrist, and then if they tried at least seven medications, most people would get better. You know, for nearly two decades, this massive taxpayer, you paid for it, funded study.
那么他在后续研究中花费的数十亿美元的研究经费，全部都是废话。它指导了这个国家的精神病学10年。它被视为最全面的东西。然后它被曝光了，因为有几个批评者。那是完全的胡扯，他们掩盖了艾蒿或圣约翰草之类的东西比Welbutrin有更好的结果。那种你可以只做CBT然后把某人送到精神科医生那里，然后如果他们尝试至少七种药物，大多数人就会好起来的想法。你知道，近二十年来，这项巨大的纳税人，你付了钱，资助的研究。
They didn't pay for it, but you paid for it. study was held up as this irrefutable proof that the medication merry-go-round of trying these different things, you know, and it cost $35 million. The initial study was cited thousands, thousands of times. If you want to say H indexes and impact factors matter, that's how much this was, one of the most cited studies. You know, if they didn't get better, if the patient didn't get better on the end of depression, you switched it six, seven times.
他们没付钱，但你付了钱。研究被视为无可辩驳的证据，证明了尝试这些不同东西的药物旋转木马，你知道，它花费了3500万美元。最初的研究被引用了成千上万次。如果你想说H指数和影响因子很重要，这就是它的程度，这是被引用最多的研究之一。你知道，如果他们没有好转，如果患者在抑郁症结束时没有好转，你换了六、七次。
And the study claimed that there was a cumulative remission rate of 67%. I mean, it told us that two-thirds of people would be cured if they just complied with this protocol of CBT and medication. And this was a lie. This forensic reanalogist, it was Pigeo that did it. And then I think the guy who popularized a lot of his work was the, what's the Madden America guy's name? If I wasn't trying to think about it, it would come to me. But he popularized a lot of that. And the original design called for the Hamilton rating scale of depression to be this primary.
而这项研究声称有67%的累积缓解率。我是说，它告诉我们，如果人们遵守这个CBT和药物的方案，三分之二的人会被治愈。这是一个谎言。这个法医重新分析，是Pigeo做的。然后我想推广他很多工作的那个人是，那个“美国疯狂”的人叫什么名字？如果我不是在努力想它，它就会出现在我脑海里。但他推广了很多那个。最初的设计要求汉密尔顿抑郁量表作为这个主要的。
outcome measure, you know, the statistical measurement. And when that scale wasn't showing the numbers that they wanted, the investigators switched to the secondary unblinded self-report, this questionnaire, the Q-I-D-S-S-R, I think. And it painted kind of a nicer picture, lots of problems with the study. So I'm not going to go through the whole thing. But a reanalysis at the end of the day exposed that there were hundreds of patients who dropped out due to side effects, and they were excluded from the failure count. So every time somebody said, this sucks, not doing it. They were like, okay, you don't count as somebody who we failed to help. And that's one of my biggest problems with all of the CBT as a gold standard. If you look at those
结果衡量标准，你知道，统计测量。当那个量表没有显示他们想要的数字时，调查人员转向了次要的非盲法自我报告，这个问卷，我想是Q-I-D-S-S-R。它描绘了一幅更美好的图景，研究中有很多问题。所以我不会把整个事情都讲一遍。但最终的重新分析揭露了有数百名患者因副作用而退出，他们被排除在失败计数之外。所以每次有人说，这太烂了，我不做了。他们就像，好吧，你不算作我们未能帮助的人。这就是我对所有作为黄金标准的CBT最大的问题之一。如果你看看那些
studies, everybody who says this sucks, so I'm not going to do it for three more months and leaves, those people count as, yeah, they didn't complete the treatment. Well, they didn't complete the treatment because it blew, right? Like, it's not a cancer trial where you get a little bit of the medication. The therapy failed to engage a patient, which is a failure of the therapy modality, of the therapist, not the patient. And because they act like this as medication that you failed to take, then you are not proof that the system doesn't work. So, you know, the most damning statistic, that's 67% after they played with the numbers, it plummeted to 35%. of people get better when they do CBT and then they try, you know, the six or seven drugs on the
研究，每个说这太烂了，所以我不会再做三个月并离开的人，那些人算作，是的，他们没有完成治疗。好吧，他们没有完成治疗是因为它太烂了，对吧？就像，这不是一个癌症试验，你得到了一点药物。治疗未能吸引患者，这是治疗方式、治疗师的失败，而不是患者的失败。而且因为他们表现得好像这是你没能服用的药物，那么你就不是系统不起作用的证据。所以，你知道，最令人沮丧的统计数据，在他们玩弄数字后的67%，暴跌至35%。人们在做CBT然后尝试，你知道，旋转木马上的六七种药物时好转，因为没有办法，你知道，我会给他们这个。我是说，我没有办法看着你说，这是对你有效的抗抑郁药。因为我无法测试。没有人能测试并说，好吧，你有这种寄生虫或你有这种细菌。所以这是治疗那种东西的药物。因为你做不到。你只能吃它们，然后看看它们是否有效。如果你讨厌它们或者不讨厌，然后你必须尝试另一种。而那种持续恢复的统计数据，所以后来，你知道，4000名进入这个试验的患者，超过4000人，我不知道总数，但4000多人，他们进入了
smerry go around because there's no way, you know, and I'll give them this. I mean, there's no way for me to look at you and say, this is the antidepressant that's going to work for you. Because I can't test. Nobody can test and say, okay, you've got this parasite or you've got this germ. And so this is the drug that treats that thing. Because you can't do that. You just got to eat them and then see if they work. if you hate them or not, and then you've got to try another one. And that statistic of sustained recovery, so later, you know, 4,000 patients who entered this trial over 4,000 and something, I don't know the whole number, but 4,000 something, they entered
试验，而这一小部分实现了缓解，并且他们保持健康，这通常应该是，报告为70%，实际上是67%，他们四舍五入。然后当考虑到这一年随访期间的退出和复发时，他们回去看了看，只有108名患者实现了抑郁症缓解。而且他们保持健康，没有复发抑郁症，不是我会称之为。他们用了“复发”这个词，但那不是那个意思。而且他们有，所以恢复率实际上是2.7%。好吧，如果你在做心脏手术、癌症治疗，而你的失败率是97.3%，那将是全国新闻。而且它不会只影响一小部分人
the trial, and this tiny fraction achieve remission, and they stay well, that was normally supposed to be, was reported at 70%, really 67, they rounded up. And then when accounting for dropouts and relapses over this one-year follow-up period where they went back and they looked at it, only 108 patients achieved remission from depression. And they stayed well without relapsing into depression, not I'll call it. They use the word relapse, but it doesn't mean that. And they had, so the recovery rate was actually 2.7%. Okay, if you're doing heart surgery, cancer treatment, and you have a failure rate of not. 97.3 percent, it would be national news. And it would not have affected a fraction of the people
这项研究及其产生的影响，影响了美国所有从事精神病学和治疗的人超过10年。为什么我必须告诉你Stardee研究？这应该是世界上最大的新闻。但它不是，它现在是旧闻了。你知道，这个，与制药行业的深层财务联系，一群人经历这些，他们表现得好像他们在暗室里搓手并策划。他们在这里确实有点这样做，因为他们改变的原因，我说那通常不是它的工作方式。这更多是一种激励结构，多人进行小组工作，没有人负责，因为每个人都有一点责任，所以没有人负责，而官僚主义是某种敌人。通常情况确实如此。但在这一项中，改为QIDS是因为他们意识到他们认为的安慰剂。
that this study and the effects that it had affected all the people doing psychiatry and therapy in America from more than 10 years. Why do I have to tell you about the Stardee study? This should be the biggest news in the world. And it's not, it's old news now. You know, this, The deep financial ties to the pharmaceutical industry, a bunch of people go through that and they act like they rub their hands in the dark room and they scheme. And they kind of did here because the reason that they changed, I say that's not usually how it works. It's more of an incentive structure that multiple people doing group work and that no one's responsible because everybody's a little bit responsible so nobody is and that bureaucracy is kind of the enemy. And usually that is the case. But in this one, the change to the QIDS was because they realized that what they thought was a placebo.
Bebo，我相信是圣约翰草，它只是一种草药，抑郁症的支点，表现优于Welbutrin。我不是在为圣约翰草辩护。我只是说，这就是那些数字在做的。这就是我们提供的治疗工作得有多有意义。而且，你知道，我对弗洛伊德有问题。我有问题，我比弗洛伊德更喜欢荣格，但我不认为每个人都需要进行分析。我不是在做那个论点，但你知道，深度心理学理解的是这些东西是系统，而不是清单，我们不再是人类不是生物机器，我们是意义创造生物，通过故事在世界上航行，当你拿走我们的故事时，你并没有让我们
Bebo, which was St. John's Ward, I believe, which is just like an herb, the fulchromity for depression, was outperforming whilebutrin. I'm not making an argument for St. John's work. I'm just saying, that's what these numbers were doing. That's how meaningful the treatment that we give was working. And, you know, I've got problems with Freud. I have problems I like Jung more than Freud, but like I don't think that everybody needs to be an analysis. I'm not making that argument but you know here's what the depth psychology is understood that these things are systems not checklists that we don't anymore humans are not biological machines we are meaning making creatures who navigate the world through story when you take our stories away you do not make us
更理性，你让我们更迷失。荣格疗法或深度心理学最大的批评之一是，这只是文学批评，被包装成治疗。我的回答是，是的。它确实有点像。它在帮助你理解你自己，这是人类如果不做就无法运作的事情。这就是它有效的原因。这也是为什么那些，你知道，
more rational you make us more lost one of the biggest criticisms of jungian therapy or depth psychology is like this is just literary criticism that's dressed up to be called therapy and my answer is like, yes. It kind of is. It's helping you make sense of yourself, which is something that humans can't function unless you do. And that's why it works. And it's also why people who are, you know,
他们认真地不想认真对待它，因为他们认为我们应该是心理健康技术员，治疗对每个人看起来都应该是一样的。但如果没有一个公式，他们会感到不安全，公式说，当患者说这个时，你说，好吧，让我从30个清单中识别出认知扭曲。这是认知扭曲。现在我需要选择四种对这种认知扭曲有效的干预措施之一。好吧，思维阻滞。我现在开那个。而那是
they serious don't want to take it seriously because they think that we're supposed to be mental health technicians, that therapy is supposed to look the same for everybody. But they're insecure without a formula that says, when the patient says this, you say, okay, let me identify the cognitive distortion out of the check. checklist of 30. Here's the cognitive distortion. Now I need to pick one of the four interventions that works for this cognitive distortion. Okay, thought-blocking. I'll prescribe that now. And that's
胡扯。这不是好的治疗。你知道，书《鬼实验室》中的“渡渡鸟群”部分，我们采访了Matt Hungoltz Hetling两次。他是我的哥们。他是个好人。他引用了一项研究，一位神经科学家，你知道，在出版物中说，他发现这相当老，学术科学已经变成了这种渡渡鸟群。那，他不是说他们像渡渡鸟一样愚蠢。他是说他们像渡渡鸟一样要灭绝了。你知道，他说我们没有很好地向人们传达科学，我们没有把科学变成一个故事。我们没有把它变成叙事。我们没有让数字讲述一个故事，以便认真对待它们。我们有点
horseshit. It's not good therapy. You know, the flock of dodo's section in the book, The Ghost Lab, we interviewed Matt Hungoltz Hetling twice. He's a buddy mine. He's a nice guy. And he quotes a study where a neuroscientist, you know, it's saying in a publication, that he finds is pretty old, that academic science has become this flock of dodoes. That, and he's not calling them dodoes like they're stupid. He's calling them dodoes like they're going to go extinct. You know, he says that we're not communicating the science well to people and that we're not making the science a story. We're not making it a narrative. We're not letting the numbers tell a story in order to take them seriously. We're kind of
剥夺了它们的意义，所以没有人认真对待它，他们转向伪科学，他们转向民间疗法，经济变得更糟，好吧，反正我也负担不起治疗，但我不太擅长承认我无法对我的处境做任何事情，因为我是人类，所以我将因果关系投射到这个不起作用的东西上，你知道，主观叙事和客观领域（如心理治疗）的主要功能之一是，它让我们从我们认为是自明的事情开始，对吧？我们不需要做研究来确定的事情，因为我们可以一致认为它们是真的。而这些事情确实，有这些不需要证据的事情，因为它们是证据所站立的基础，
stripping them of meaning and so no one is taking it seriously and they're pivoting to pseudoscience and they're pivoting to folk remedies and the economy gets worse and well hell I can't afford therapy anyway but I'm not really good at admitting that I can't do anything about my situation because I'm a human and so I'm going to project causation on this thing that doesn't work and you know one of those primary functions of a subjective narrative and an objective field like psychotherapy is that it let's us start with things that we consider self-evidence, right? Things that we don't need to do a study to determine because we can just all agree that they are true. And these things do, there are these things that don't need evidence because they are grounds upon which evidence stands,
对吧？就像，独立宣言是怎么开始的？他们说，我们认为这些真理是不言而喻的。这些是我们的价值观。人人生而平等。人人生而自由。你应该能够追求幸福。他们没有说，嗯，追求幸福和人的自由以及人的平等是，我们做了一个双盲、随机对照试验，我们认为这是一个好主意，因为它导致了这些效果。他们没有说，如果他们这样做，人们会赚更多的钱。他们只是说，这是我们开始这个国家的原因，因为这些事情是真的。而我们，你可以说，嗯，如果那是妄想呢？好吧，我认为当你没有不言而喻的真理时，你冒着让大众变得妄想的更大风险
right? Like, how does the declaration of independence start? They say, we hold these truths to be self-evident. These are our values. Men are created equal. Men are created free. You should be able to pursue happiness. They don't say, well, the pursuit of happiness and the freedom of men and the equality of men is, we did a double-blind, randomized controlled trial, and we think that it's a good idea because it results in these effects. They don't say, it makes people more money if they do this. They just say, this is the reason that we're starting this country, because these things are true. And we, you can say, well, what if that's delusional? well, I think that you run a greater risk of making masses of people delusional when you don't have self-evident truths
因为大多数人同意不言而喻的事情，这些事情是团结的，而那些前卫和奇怪的事情，大多数人往往不同意。而生物医学模型没有办法容纳这些不言而喻的真理，因为它们是不可测量的。你不能对人类尊严进行随机对照试验。你知道，Martin Heidegger理解这一点，他警告说科学和技术正在成为自我辩护的系统，只问某事是否可以做，而不是是否应该做。我们现在正在看着这种情况随着大型语言模型和人工智能而上演。科技行业正在煮沸海水并消耗我们大量的资源来构建这些巨大的系统。而人工智能热潮是一个泡沫。
because most people agree on things that are self-evident that are uniting and that things that are fringe and weird often most people don't agree with. And the biomedical model has no way to accommodate these self-evident truths because they're not measurable. You can't run a randomized controlled trial on human dignity. You know, Martin Heidegger, understood this, and he warned that science and technology were becoming self-justifying systems that asked only whether something could be done, and not whether or not it should. And we're watching this play out right now with large language models and AI. The tech industry is boiling seawater and consuming enormous amounts of our resources to build these huge systems. And the AI boom is a bubble.
人工智能热潮是一个泡沫。它会破裂。它可能会让谷歌拥有Gemini，然后是一些自托管模型和一些给国家行为体甚至公司用的超级昂贵的东西，但你10年后不会有ChatGPT，伙计。你不会。你知道，我们应该这样做吗？我们是否应该为了最大的泡沫之一而从根本上重组我们的经济，就像进行我们无法救助的最大的实验之一？这不会是通用汽车的救助，因为政府金库里没有足够的钱来支撑这些永远无法赚回投入其中的数万亿美元的公司价值。
The AI boom is a bubble. It's going to pop. It's probably going to leave Google with Gemini and then some self-hosting models and some super expensive stuff for state actors and maybe corporations, but you're not going to have chat cheap EBT in 10 years, man. Like you're not. You know, should we do this? Should we be fundamentally restructuring our economy for one of the biggest bubbles, like running one of the biggest experiments that we can't bail these out? This won't be the bailout of GM because there's not enough money in government coffers to prop up the value of these companies that can never make back the trillions of dollars that have been
你知道，我们能认识到我们有一个，宜居的星球可能是一个自我证明的目标吗？我们能认识到拥有一种将与永恒哲学互动的心理治疗可能比另一个证明手册化干预措施小效应量的元分析更有价值吗？现在这就是我所说的重新引入叙事的意思。我不是指用神话取代证据，我不是指用伪科学取代科学，我的意思是修复科学以认识到我们的大脑需要故事，因为它们被设置为那样思考。如果我们需要一种药物，如果我们需要一种缓解痛苦的止痛药，它将在某人能够创造意义中找到。我是说认识到事实并不能说明
poured into them. You know, can we just recognize that we have, a livable planet is probably a self-evidencing goal can we recognize that having a psychotherapy that will engage with a perennial philosophy might be more valuable than another meta-analysis demonstrating a small effect size for manualized interventions now this is what i mean by reintroducing narrative i don't mean replacing evidence with myth i don't mean replacing science with pseudoscience i mean fixing science to recognize that our brains need stories because they are set up to think that way. And if we need a medicine, if we need an anodyne for our suffering, it's going to be found in somebody being able to make meaning. I mean recognizing that the facts do not speak for
倾注其中。你知道，我们能否承认，拥有一个宜居的星球本身就是一个不言自明的目标？我们能否承认，拥有一种能与永恒哲学相结合的心理治疗，可能比另一项证明手册式干预措施效果微乎其微的荟萃分析更有价值？我所说的重新引入叙事，并不是指用神话取代证据，也不是指用伪科学取代科学，而是指修正科学，使其认识到我们的大脑需要故事，因为它们天生就是这样思考的。如果我们确实需要一种药物，一种缓解痛苦的镇痛剂，那么它一定存在于某个人能够创造意义的能力中。我的意思是，要认识到事实本身并不能说明一切。
themselves. Data requires interpretation. Interpretation requires a framework and frameworks are stories. The story that science forgot is the story of science itself. It is the story of how inquiry emerged from human communities trying to understand their world. world with the bare bones. We can recover a story. We can rebuild the connections that the academic silos have severed and there's people doing it all over the country now. It's not going to be done by one person. It's not going to be done by hero. It's going to be done by people giving a shit. If academic science has become a flock of dodo's clinical practice has become something arguably worse and it's become a reenactment of the Stanley Milgram experiment where
本身。数据需要解读。解读需要框架，而框架就是故事。科学所遗忘的故事，正是科学本身的故事。这是一个关于探究精神如何从人类试图理解世界的社区中萌芽的故事。我们能用仅存的残骸还原一个故事。我们可以重建那些被学术孤岛所切断的联系，现在全国各地都有人在做这件事。这不会由一个人完成，也不会由英雄完成，而是由那些真正关心这件事的人来完成。如果学术科学已经变成了一群渡渡鸟，那么临床实践则变得更糟，它已经变成了斯坦利·米尔格拉姆实验的重演，其中
the system plays the role of authority figure and the patient plays the victim. That's the one where He shocked people. Stanley Milgram was the 1961 study about the human capacity for evil and basically saying that Nazism could happen anywhere. But its deeper lesson was about the capacity for distance. When the subject had to physically touch the victim, compliance with the order to shock the person, I'll back up.
系统扮演权威角色，而病人扮演受害者。就是那个他电击人们的实验。斯坦利·米尔格拉姆在1961年的研究是关于人类作恶的能力，基本上是在说纳粹主义可能发生在任何地方。但其更深层的教训是关于距离感的能力。当受试者必须亲手触碰受害者时，对电击命令的服从度，让我退一步说。
The Milgram experiment you probably learned about in Psych 101, but it's where the guy is just wearing a white, coat. He's not introduced as a doctor. He's just in a white coat and he says, hey, shock the guy in the chair. And the voltages go up until these ones are marked with lethal dosages. It's not real electricity, but the guy in the chair is like, ah, please don't shock me. And most people did it. But if you ask them to reach out and touch the person first, fewer of them did. And when the subject was asked to physically touch the person, 30% less people would shock the person that they had to touch whether than just look at. And that white coat.
米尔格拉姆实验你可能在心理学入门课上学过，就是那个穿白大褂的人。他没有被介绍为医生，他只是穿着白大褂，然后说，嘿，电击椅子上那个人。电压一直升高，直到标记为致命剂量。这不是真的电，但椅子上的人会说，啊，请不要电我。大多数人都照做了。但如果你让他们先伸手触碰那个人，照做的人就少了。当受试者被要求亲手触碰那个人时，电击对方的人数减少了30%，而不是仅仅看着。还有那件白大褂。
The coat retained its authority when it created this buffer between the human actions and their consequences. You know, modern psychotherapy has built this massive administrative white coat that separates the healer from the healed. And this is not a metaphor. It's a structural reality that is actively driving patients out of the profession and into the arms of pseudoscience. You know, for a patient in crisis, the evidence-based system, it functions as, and again, I'm not talking about using science. I'm not talking about what I consider good evidence. I'm talking about what academic clinical psychology right now considers good evidence. You know, there's a study on health care and administrative burdens,
当白大褂在人类行为及其后果之间制造了这种缓冲时，它就保留了权威。你知道，现代心理治疗建立了一种庞大的行政白大褂，将治疗者与被治疗者隔离开来。这不仅仅是一个比喻，而是一个结构性的现实，它正在积极地将病人赶出这个行业，推向伪科学的怀抱。你知道，对于处于危机中的病人来说，循证系统，它的功能是——我再说一遍，我不是在谈论使用科学，我不是在谈论我所认为的好证据，我是在谈论学术临床心理学目前认为的好证据。你知道，有一项关于医疗保健和行政负担的研究，
and it shows that the psychological cost of navigating and billing insurance denials and intake forums, it acts as this friction that hits the most vulnerable people the hardest because it drives up the cost of health care. And we ask trauma survivors to retell their stories. you know, to three different intake coordinators before they even see a therapist if you're at a major hospital or a clinic for triage. And this process itself is re-traumatizing. When we finally reach a provider, you know, they're often met with this biomedical gaze, which is a checklist-driven assessment that reduces their complex narrative of suffering.
它表明，处理和结算保险拒赔以及填写表格的心理成本，就像一种摩擦力，对最脆弱的人群打击最大，因为它推高了医疗成本。我们要求创伤幸存者重述他们的故事，你知道，在见到治疗师之前，如果是在大型医院或诊所进行分诊，他们得向三位不同的分诊协调员重述。这个过程本身就是一种再创伤。当我们最终见到提供者时，你知道，他们往往会遇到这种生物医学凝视，这是一种基于清单的评估，它简化了病人复杂的痛苦叙事。
I can't hear it. It reduces it to a code for billing. And as the, you know, Australian psychological society pointed out, like the chemical imbalance theory and the medicalize, excuse me, the medicalization of distress, it's failed to reduce stigma, and instead it's left patients feeling defective and then unheard. And the result is a profound low trust environment. You know, Theodore Porter in his book, Trust in Numbers, argues that we rely on strict mechanical numbers when we do not trust people. We use the DSM and manualized protocols because insurers do not trust clinicians to judge, and clinicians do not trust themselves to
我听不到。它将其简化为计费代码。正如澳大利亚心理学会所指出的，化学失衡理论和医疗化——抱歉，痛苦的医疗化——未能减少污名化，反而让病人感到自己有缺陷，且无人倾听。结果是一个极度缺乏信任的环境。你知道，西奥多·波特在他的书《信任数字》中认为，当我们不信任人时，就会依赖严格的机械数字。我们使用DSM和手册化的协议，因为保险公司不信任临床医生的判断，而临床医生也不信任自己去
deviate and the this creates this fundamental schism that happens and explains why the profession feels like it's cracking in half on one side you have the academic researchers who are incentivized by grant funding and publication metrics a lot of times the the way that colleges promote you and tenure you and give you a price point you know salary is your ability to get cited which results in these giant meta analyses that are completely useless but they're going to get cited a lot and it's like content what we're publishing an academic psych now a lot of it feels like content written for a search engine but not for a
偏离。这造成了根本性的分裂，也解释了为什么这个行业感觉正在裂成两半。一方面是学术研究人员，他们受到拨款资助和出版指标的激励。很多时候，大学提拔你、给你终身教职并给你定价（你知道，薪水）的方式，就是你被引用的能力，这导致了这些完全没用但会被大量引用的大型荟萃分析。这就像内容，我们现在在学术心理学中发表的很多东西，感觉就像是为搜索引擎编写的内容，而不是为
human like one of those pages you click on and it answers your search query and it's top ranking but when you actually read it it's just kind of like word salad because they're trying to deal with so much data that somebody else has to cite them and then that becomes what the incentive structure is promoting not real psychology. And, you know, to get these rewards, they must isolate variables and create reproducible, manualized protocols. Just to do the study, they have to strip the story out, the thing that makes therapy work to turn it into this formula that will prove what will work for everyone. And there are best practices that we could use science to determine. There are interventions.
人类编写的。就像你点击的那些页面，它回答了你的搜索查询，排名很高，但当你真正阅读时，它就像文字沙拉，因为他们试图处理如此多的数据，以便别人引用他们，而这正是激励结构所促进的，而不是真正的心理学。而且，你知道，为了获得这些奖励，他们必须隔离变量并创建可重复的、手册化的协议。仅仅为了做这项研究，他们就必须剥离故事，即让治疗起作用的东西，将其变成一个能证明对每个人都有效的公式。我们可以利用科学来确定最佳实践。有一些干预措施。
There are neurobiological changes that we could measure. We don't do that. We don't research, not just what works, but what is interesting, which is not boring as sin. Even the people that write this stuff don't want to read it, talk to one of them. And so, you know, on the other side of that split, you've got these clinicians who are incentivized by patient outcomes, and they're in the room with the messiness of real life, and they see that the manualized protocols fail trauma patients. And so they improvise, and then they integrate, and they use their intuition. When this academic looks at the clinical, you know, the academic, a lot of times, like when they see the clinician, they just see this cowboy who ignores data and it's doing whatever.
我们可以测量神经生物学的变化。但我们不这样做。我们不研究，不仅是研究什么有效，还有什么是有趣的，而不是枯燥得要命。即使是写这些东西的人也不想读它，去和他们中的任何一个人谈谈就知道了。所以，你知道，在分裂的另一边，你有那些受到病人预后激励的临床医生，他们身处现实生活的混乱之中，他们看到手册化的协议对创伤病人无效。于是他们即兴发挥，整合并运用他们的直觉。当学术界的人看着临床医生时，你知道，学术界的人很多时候，当他们看到临床医生时，他们只看到这个无视数据、胡作非为的牛仔。
Why are you doing EMDR? EMDR is not evidence-based. It's because it worked for the person at the training or they saw it work. You know, I haven't met anybody who's an EMDR zealot where EMDR didn't heal them. EMDR, I don't think, is incredibly generalizable. I think it does miracles for 30% of people. I think it does nothing for another 70%. That doesn't mean it doesn't work. It's another tool that you have that you try.
你为什么要用EMDR？EMDR不是循证的。这是因为它对培训时的人有效，或者他们看到它有效。你知道，我还没见过哪个EMDR狂热者不是被EMDR治愈的。我不认为EMDR具有极强的普适性。我认为它对30%的人创造了奇迹。我认为它对另外70%的人毫无作用。但这并不意味着它无效。它是你拥有的另一种尝试工具。
And if you don't get a response, you stop and then you move on to a new tool. It's not a black or white. Like this is this works or it doesn't. And this is why research is no longer informing therapy practice as much as it should be. That's why I wrote that article about the schism between academic and clinical psychology and why they're in two different worlds, which is not good for the profession. We've created these two different languages. And the researcher speaks in P values and population averages.
如果你没有得到回应，你就停止，然后转向新的工具。这不是非黑即白的。不是说这有效或无效。这就是为什么研究不再像它应该的那样为治疗实践提供信息。这就是为什么我写了那篇关于学术心理学和临床心理学之间分裂的文章，以及为什么它们处于两个不同的世界，这对这个行业来说不是好事。我们创造了这两种不同的语言。研究人员用P值和人口平均数说话。
And the clinician speaks in case studies and individual. breakthroughs. And in this low trust environment, you know, if you read my Theodore reporter article, trust in numbers, he's an interesting guy. Numbers are what you revert to when you have a low trust environment. It creates this vacuum that wellness influencers are all too happy to fill. And we, you know, mock the public for turning to these unverified supplements on TikTok and, you know, snake venom or Joe Rogan or whatever, but like the diagnosticians who are telling people about quantum mysticism, making their soul vibrate to chakras and like all this stuff, they're telling a story,
而临床医生用案例研究和个人突破说话。在这个低信任环境中，你知道，如果你读过我的西奥多·波特文章《信任数字》，他是个有趣的人。数字是你处于低信任环境时所回归的东西。它创造了一个真空，健康网红们非常乐意填补。我们，你知道，嘲笑公众转向TikTok上这些未经证实的补充剂，还有，你知道，蛇毒或乔·罗根之类的东西，但那些告诉人们关于量子神秘主义、让灵魂与脉轮共振等等的诊断师，他们是在讲一个故事，
which is why people are listening to them. We have to ask these influencers, like we have to ask us, like, what are these people providing that we're not? What are these influencers giving to people that feels good? And maybe that should be a part of the initial intake and triage of therapy instead of a false hope. It could be the thing that prepares them for an evidence-based practice that is actually effective. They're providing a narrative. They're providing connection. Maybe it's parisocial, but they're providing a connection to a person. And it feels like a high trust experience.
这就是为什么人们在听他们说话。我们必须问这些网红，就像我们必须问我们自己一样，这些人提供了什么而我们没有提供？这些网红给人们提供了什么让他们感觉良好的东西？也许这应该成为治疗初步摄入和分诊的一部分，而不是虚假的希望。它可能是让他们为真正有效的循证实践做好准备的东西。他们提供了一种叙事。他们提供了联系。也许是准社会关系，但他们提供了一种与人的联系。这感觉像是一种高信任体验。
Whereas modern therapy for a lot of people in these studies that I'm quoting, it doesn't feel like they trust the system after they participate. And it doesn't feel like they'll ever go back because the system sucks. You know, recent analysis suggested that wellness fads thrive, not because people are stupid, but because the influencers offer this feeling of personal validation that the medical system denies them. And even AI chatbots are now being described by users as more humane than doctors because the AI listens to the whole story without looking at a watch or a checklist. And when a patient is told by a doctor that their pain is, you know, idiopathic or psychosomatic because it doesn't show up on you know lab tests and then an
而现代治疗对于我所引用的这些研究中的许多人来说，参与后感觉并不信任这个系统。而且感觉他们再也不会回去了，因为这个系统烂透了。你知道，最近的分析表明，健康时尚之所以盛行，不是因为人们愚蠢，而是因为网红提供了医疗系统所否认他们的那种个人认可感。甚至人工智能聊天机器人现在也被用户描述为比医生更有人情味，因为人工智能会听完整的故事，而不看手表或清单。当病人被医生告知他们的疼痛是，你知道，特发性的或心因性的，因为它没有在实验室检查中显示出来，然后一个
influencer tells them i see you i believe you and here is a story about why this is happening you know the patient will choose the influencer every time and the trust gap drives them away from care that might actually help and towards solutions that feel good but they don't do anything. And because that style of the girls with the crystals in their hair or whatever, doing yoga with perfect makeup on top of a mountain in Denver or something, you know, because that style works, now we're seeing it everywhere. I always make a joke about how like politicians around like the beginning of the Trump administration on both sides like started talking like avatar characters or influencers where like,
网红告诉他们，我看见你了，我相信你，这是关于为什么会发生这种情况的故事，你知道，病人每次都会选择网红。信任差距将他们推离了可能真正有帮助的护理，转向了感觉良好但毫无作用的解决方案。而且因为那种留着水晶发饰的女孩风格，或者无论什么，在丹佛山顶化着完美妆容做瑜伽，你知道，因为那种风格有效，现在我们到处都能看到它。我总是开玩笑说，特朗普政府初期两边的政客开始像化身角色或网红一样说话，就像，
if you've seen Avatar, the James Cameron one, they'll be like, I feel you, Jake Sully, Jake Sully, I see you. You know, there's these kind of like, I'm not criticizing the movie, they're fine, but like they have that, you know, kind of new age thing. And then like at the beginning of this administration, there was like Nancy Pelosi and Katie Britt,
如果你看过《阿凡达》，詹姆斯·卡梅隆的那部，他们会说，我感受到了你，杰克·萨利，杰克·萨利，我看见你了。你知道，有这种，我不是在批评这部电影，它们很好，但它们有那种，你知道，新时代的味道。然后就像这届政府开始时，有南希·佩洛西和凯蒂·布里特，
both like looking into the camera and being like, we see you, we feel you, Americans. And it was like, whoa, dog. don't feel me okay like past Medicaid for all or build roads or schools like I I don't need validation from y'all but I think that that's the reason that the culture is moving towards that style which is not good you know and this leaves this ethical psychotherapist not I'm not saying I'm ethical but the ethical psychotherapist I mean I'm ethical but I wasn't just talking about myself I'm saying
都盯着镜头说，我们看见你们了，我们感受到了你们，美国人。就像是，哇，伙计。别感受我，好吗？通过全民医疗补助，或者修建道路或学校，我不需要你们的认可，但我认为这就是文化向那种风格转变的原因，这不好。你知道，这让这位有道德的心理治疗师——我不是说我是有道德的，我是指有道德的心理治疗师，我是说我有道德，但我不是在谈论我自己，我是说
it leaves this person who is trying to be an ethical ethical psychotherapist that wants to probably follow the science and try and interpret it, but then also figure out things that work in the room and where manualized therapies don't and deviate from them, they're forced to participate in the system where, you know, we know that it's alienating the very people we're trying to help and we're trained to value the therapeutic alliance or the bond of trust above all else. And yet we work in the system designed to separate with paperwork and time limits and insurance remits that don't pay because the system's not clear. Do you know how easy it would be to make an app tomorrow where you walk into a clinic and it's like, oh, we see you're on this
这让这位试图成为有道德的心理治疗师的人，他可能想遵循科学并尝试解读它，但同时也想找出在诊室里有效的东西，而在手册化治疗无效的地方偏离它们，他们被迫参与这个系统，你知道，我们知道它正在疏远我们试图帮助的人，而我们受训要将治疗联盟或信任纽带置于一切之上。然而，我们在一个旨在通过文书工作、时间限制和不支付的保险汇款来制造隔阂的系统中工作，因为系统不清晰。你知道明天做一个应用程序有多容易吗？你走进一家诊所，它显示，哦，我们看到你在用这个
site, but you don't have prior authorization here, your appointment's at five or, oh, you know, here's your insurance app just showed you like six psychotherapists in the area. And these are the people that take your insurance. And here's their availability. Like that app could be done in two minutes. The reason it doesn't exist is because if you're afraid, because you've had this bad experience before and insurance billing is a complete nightmare where the provider can't even tell you, you know, what your insurance benefits are, which is the position I'm in, all the time. This is why I tell people, call your insurance company because it's legal for them to lie to you. It's illegal for them to lie to you. It's not illegal for them to lie to me.
网站，但你这里没有预先授权，你的预约在五点，或者，哦，你知道，这是你的保险应用程序，刚刚为你显示了该地区的六位心理治疗师。这些人接受你的保险。这是他们的空档。那个应用程序两分钟就能做完。它不存在的原因是，如果你害怕，因为你之前有过这种糟糕的经历，而且保险结算是一场彻底的噩梦，提供者甚至无法告诉你，你知道，你的保险福利是什么，这就是我一直所处的立场。这就是为什么我告诉人们，给你的保险公司打电话，因为他们合法地可以对你撒谎。他们对你撒谎是合法的。他们对我撒谎是不合法的。
And so they will. And when I call and I wait in line and I get this information, a lot of the time, now it's wrong. And the person's mad at me and I'm just telling them with their insurance company told me when I gave them the benefit. But they can do that. And they're not on the hook for it when they make those mistakes. It would be incredibly easy to simplify this process. They don't simplify it because they don't want it to work because they want you to be afraid and they want it to be complicated because the more that you are afraid and the more that it is complicated, the less likely you are to jump through all of the hoops to get them to pay for the money that they owe you and the treatment that you need. That's why it's hard. If we want to stop this exodus and we want
所以他们会撒谎。当我打电话排队等待并得到这些信息时，很多时候，现在它是错的。那个人对我生气，而我只是告诉他们当我提供福利时他们的保险公司告诉我的话。但他们可以这样做。当他们犯这些错误时，他们不需要负责。简化这个过程会非常容易。他们不简化它，因为他们不想让它工作，因为他们希望你害怕，他们希望它复杂，因为你越害怕，它越复杂，你就越不可能跳过所有的障碍让他们支付他们欠你的钱和你需要的治疗。这就是为什么它很难。如果我们想停止这种出走，如果我们想
to heal the split, we need structural change. We can't just hope for better insurance or reimbursement. We need to change what we consider valid science. And we first have to re-legitimize the system, the system of a person, get rid of checklist and under the stand these things as processes. Because of my website, I have to do all this SEO. One of the worst things that search engine optimization and there's schema markup and code and all the stuff that I wish I never had to learn. But now that I know it, like the worst thing that you can do is be like, what are the top 10 things I have to do for my website? What order do I need to improve my website? Check, check, check, check, check. Because it doesn't work. Google won't see it. You can do all those things like a
治愈这种分裂，我们需要结构性变革。我们不能只希望有更好的保险或报销。我们需要改变我们认为有效的科学。我们首先必须重新合法化这个系统，即人的系统，摆脱清单，并将这些东西理解为过程。因为我的网站，我必须做所有这些SEO。搜索引擎优化最糟糕的事情之一，还有模式标记和代码以及所有我希望我从未学过的东西。但现在我知道了，最糟糕的事情就是像，我必须为我的网站做哪10件事？我需要按什么顺序改进我的网站？勾选，勾选，勾选，勾选，勾选。因为它不起作用。谷歌不会看到它。你可以像做
checklist. You have to understand them as parts of a system that are balancing each other out that have tradeoffs that have an effect on each other and the human mind works like that too you know we have to replace those checklist with aggregated data of those randomized controlled trials we need to bring back qualitative not quantitative study we need journals that publish rigorous detailed accounts of what actually happens in the room when a patient gets better and look at the people that are effective and see what they're doing you know second we need to build open open source repositories for clinical observation like currently the wisdom of the field is locked behind the profit paywalls were lost in the private notes of isolated therapists and we need a wikipedia of
清单一样做所有这些事情。你必须将它们理解为相互平衡、有权衡、相互影响的系统的一部分，人类思维也是这样工作的。你知道，我们必须用这些随机对照试验的汇总数据来取代那些清单，我们需要带回定性而非定量的研究。我们需要发表严谨、详细的记录的期刊，记录当病人好转时诊室里到底发生了什么，看看那些有效的人在做什么。你知道，第二，我们需要为临床观察建立开源存储库，因为目前该领域的智慧被锁在利润付费墙后面，迷失在孤立治疗师的私人笔记中。我们需要一个临床实践的维基百科，
clinical practice where thousands of clinicians can document what they're seeing in real time if 10,000 therapists report that semantic processing helps complex trauma that is data that is set that rivals any randomized controlled trial because it's somebody who did it yesterday not a therapy that somebody invented 10 years ago then they wrote a book on five years ago then the book got popular than it got on Oprah and now because it's on Oprah and in the New York Times and they're famous now they're going to research it and on the study costs it 13 million dollars and it took three years and now you can do it this watered down version of this thing that that person figured out a decade ago stop doing that it doesn't work the world is sick
成千上万的临床医生可以实时记录他们所看到的东西。如果1万名治疗师报告说语义处理有助于复杂创伤，那是可以媲美任何随机对照试验的数据，因为这是昨天有人做过的事情，而不是10年前有人发明的一种疗法，然后5年前写了一本书，然后书流行了，上了奥普拉节目，现在因为上了奥普拉和《纽约时报》，他们出名了，现在他们要研究它，研究成本1300万美元，花了三年时间，现在你可以做这个版本了，这个那个人十年前想出来的东西的淡化版。别再那样做了，它没用，世界病了。
we need it to be able to be there's no reason to do it it it benefits nobody other than the bottom line of some people you know third we need to teach philosophy and narrative and graduate schools and while you're at it go ahead and add like anthropology and some neuroscience to therapists you're talking about polyvagal theory and half the people don't know what these words mean because they don't know how the brain works which I took classes and to learn because it's my job you know we are training technicians when we should be training healers and a therapist who knows how to read a spreadsheet but they don't know
我们需要它能够存在，没有理由这样做，它除了某些人的底线外，对任何人都没有好处。你知道，第三，我们需要在研究生院教授哲学和叙事，顺便说一句，继续给治疗师加上人类学和一些神经科学。你在谈论多迷走神经理论，而一半的人不知道这些词是什么意思，因为他们不知道大脑是如何工作的，我上了课去学习，因为这是我的工作。你知道，我们正在培训技术人员，而我们本应该培训治疗师。一个知道如何阅读电子表格但不知道
to how to understand a story is useless to human beings in crisis if we do not offer therapy that is human and narrative deeply relational we will continue to lose our patience to those who do, even if what they are offering is a lie. And we often treat mathematics as if it was this bedrock of reality itself, like the real stuff was a number. Numbers represent reality. They are the mirror. They're not the thing.
如何理解故事的治疗师，对处于危机中的人类来说是无用的。如果我们不提供人性化、叙事性、深度关系化的治疗，我们将继续失去我们的病人给那些这样做的人，即使他们提供的是谎言。我们经常把数学当作现实本身的基石，好像真实的东西就是一个数字。数字代表现实。它们是镜子。它们不是事物本身。
The thing speaks for itself. Numbers are a way of recording it imperfectly. And we act as if a P value is a piece of the universe, like a rock or a proton. but we have to remember that math is not the thing itself. It's a representation of the thing. It is a map. It is not the territory. It's a mirror.
事物本身会说话。数字是一种不完美记录它的方式。我们表现得好像P值是宇宙的一部分，就像一块岩石或一个质子。但我们必须记住，数学不是事物本身。它是事物的表现。它是一张地图。它不是领土。它是一面镜子。
It is not the face. You know, Theodore Porter entrust in numbers. It's a great book. Read it. He reminds us that we, you know, we reach for these mirrors when we do not trust our own eyes. But the mirror is useless without someone to look into it and interpret the reflection. Data by itself is pointless. It's a pile of bricks without an architect.
它不是脸。你知道，西奥多·波特在《信任数字》中。这是一本好书。读读它。他提醒我们，我们，你知道，当我们不信任自己的眼睛时，我们会伸手去拿这些镜子。但没有人在镜子里看并解读反射，镜子是无用的。数据本身毫无意义。它是一堆没有建筑师的砖块。
and it requires interpretation to become meaning, and interpretation is fundamentally a narrative act. And when we try to make a purely objective study, we're still telling a story. We're still saying these numbers represent this phenomenon. The problem with the Sardee study was not the data. The data was fine. It was the interpretation because the numbers told a story
它需要解读才能成为意义，而解读从根本上说是一种叙事行为。当我们试图做一个纯粹客观的研究时，我们仍然在讲一个故事。我们仍然在说这些数字代表这种现象。Sardee研究的问题不在于数据。数据没问题。问题在于解读，因为数字讲了一个故事，
that you're not allowed to tell anymore, which is that the system did not work. What was the evidence-based practice gold standard has failed? And so they changed the story. You know, then when you research something, you say, these numbers mean this thing. And another research comes along, looks at the numbers and says, no, this story does, it represents that because look at them from this lens. Look at them from this way. You know, that conflict, a lot of people say the science changes when you point out these conflicts.
一个你不再被允许讲的故事，那就是系统没有工作。什么是循证实践的黄金标准已经失败了？所以他们改变了故事。你知道，当你研究某件事时，你说，这些数字意味着这件事。然后另一项研究出现了，看着这些数字说，不，这个故事，它代表那个，因为从这个镜头看它们。从这个方式看它们。你知道，那种冲突，很多人说当你指出这些冲突时科学就变了。
Yes, it changes. But it needs to change based on improving lenses, not based on our subjective. blind spots because the problem with not having a story by pretending like oh we're just going to be a flock of dodoes and this is for experts and we're just going to look at numbers and data because we're evidence-based creatures we're logical beings we're not emotional beings that sometimes have logic we're logical beings that sometimes have inconvenient emotions the problem with that conception is that you don't see the story that you're telling with it which is the problem with academic psychology right now you know um the great some of those big biggest breakthroughs
是的，它变了。但它需要基于改进镜头而改变，而不是基于我们主观的盲点，因为没有故事的问题在于，假装像，哦，我们只是要成为一群渡渡鸟，这是给专家看的，我们只是要看数字和数据，因为我们是循证生物，我们是逻辑生物，我们不是有时有逻辑的情感生物，我们是有时有不便情感的逻辑生物。这种概念的问题在于，你没有看到你用它讲的故事，这就是学术心理学目前的问题。你知道，嗯，那些最伟大的突破，
history. Like, they didn't come from people who crunched numbers. They came from people who could see the story that the numbers were telling. And these stories are really damn interesting. And they're often stranger and more beautiful than the representation. I mean, like, you don't have to go to a mystic like Kukule who invented the benzene ring, which made you be able to get diesel fuel out of a charcoal, basically, which is why diesel fuel took on. I'm not going to go through that. But, yeah. Look up how a, uh, uh, GM, uh, GM, and Ford, you know, Henry Ford being super racist, like, sort of let the Nazis happen because they gave a lot of, like, the information on how to get charcoal out of diesel fuel to the Nazis
历史。它们不是来自那些处理数字的人。它们来自那些能看到数字所讲述的故事的人。这些故事真的该死地有趣。它们通常比表现形式更陌生、更美丽。我的意思是，你不必去找像凯库勒那样的神秘主义者，他发明了苯环，这让你基本上能从木炭中提取柴油，这就是为什么柴油燃料流行起来的原因。我不打算讲那个。但是，是的。查查通用汽车和福特，你知道，亨利·福特非常种族主义，就像，某种程度上让纳粹发生，因为他们给了纳粹很多关于如何从柴油燃料中提取木炭的信息，
because, yeah, I don't know, they liked Nazis. And, like, part of that is the reason why World War II was ever able to happen since Germany had no oil until you taught them how to make it out of charcoal. But, you know, Kukle discovered that in a dream. And when you look at the uroboros, he saw the urobarus, the snake eating its own tail, the infinity symbol, and then he started thinking about molecules and what the snake was telling him. And then he realized, like, oh, this is what the molecule is doing. It's an interchange, and you can affect that interchange, and you can synthesize, you know, coal from oil
因为，是的，我不知道，他们喜欢纳粹。而且，某种程度上，这就是第二次世界大战之所以能够发生的原因，因为德国在教他们如何用木炭制造它之前没有石油。但是，你知道，凯库勒在梦中发现了这一点。当你看到衔尾蛇时，他看到了衔尾蛇，蛇吃自己的尾巴，无限符号，然后他开始思考分子以及蛇在告诉他什么。然后他意识到，哦，这就是分子在做的事情。这是一个交换，你可以影响那个交换，你可以合成，你知道，从石油中提取煤，
because they have this same structure and something else goes here. You know, the data didn't lead him there. And you don't have to go to the mystics. I mean, look at quantum physics. Like the raw math of all of quantum mechanics is never somebody who gets to the math, and then you know they hit a hole in the math like that's how you get some theories that kind of patch holes in these numbers but when you have physicists like schrodinger or werner heisenberg when they look at data they see it's this story about uncertainty um you know uh that the cat is both alive and dead because the particle hasn't been observed um they didn't calculate they interpreted um Einstein and um Oppenheimer you know like Einstein said when he's discovering relativity. Well, what if there's a guy in an elevator,
因为它们有这种相同的结构，而别的东西在这里。你知道，数据并没有引导他到那里。你不必去找神秘主义者。我的意思是，看看量子物理学。量子力学的所有原始数学从来都不是某个人得到数学，然后你知道他们遇到了数学中的一个洞，这就是你如何得到一些修补这些数字中漏洞的理论，但当你有像薛定谔或维尔纳·海森堡这样的物理学家时，当他们看数据时，他们看到这是一个关于不确定性的故事，嗯，你知道，猫既是活的又是死的，因为粒子没有被观察到，他们没有计算，他们解读了。爱因斯坦和奥本海默，你知道，就像爱因斯坦在发现相对论时所说的。好吧，如果电梯里有一个人，
and the guy in the elevator is going, like, straight up. Newton says that gravity is like a force, and that movement inertia is, or movement and inertia is this force that acts universally and never changes, like gravity or like light, but I don't really think that. What if a light beams hitting the guy, and he's moving up in this glass elevator in space, and then a hand comes out of nowhere that's giant,
电梯里的人正在，就像，直线上升。牛顿说重力就像一种力，运动惯性，或者运动和惯性是一种普遍作用且永不改变的力，就像重力或光，但我真的不这么认为。如果一束光射向那个人，而他在太空中的这个玻璃电梯里向上移动，然后一只巨大的手突然出现，
it grabs him and jerks him to the side, I think that there would be, you know, a recoil dynamic. So that doesn't mean that momentum is this straight force like Newton thought. It means that space itself has a shape and that gravity and velocity are this in this relay, and time are in this relationship that when you move space quickly, empty space, it takes a minute to change and bend. Like he saw that in his mind. He didn't like math. Oppenheimer, you know, he took Einstein.
它抓住他并把他猛地拉向一边，我想会有，你知道，一种反冲动力。所以这并不意味着动量是牛顿所想的那种直线力。这意味着空间本身有一种形状，重力和速度处于这种关系中，时间处于这种关系中，当你快速移动空间时，空的空间，它需要一分钟来改变和弯曲。就像他在脑海中看到的那样。他不怎么喜欢数学。奥本海默，你知道，他采用了爱因斯坦的理论。
I'm not a quantum physicist, so if I'm getting some of this a little bit off, you know, come at me. But like Oppenheimer, from what I understand, you know, he just took classical physics to the most extreme breaking point where he said, what if there's a singularity where you compress everything down into one tiny atom? What if, you know, there is the end of velocity? What if there's the end of space? You know, what if there is like more gravity, then could enough gravity to suck up light and then said oh it broke you know you can't have these extremes so there must be this dualism of probability where there's things that haven't happened yet so we can't calculate them all the way because they haven't happened they're going to happen and they're in the process
我不是量子物理学家，所以如果我把其中的一些弄得有点偏差，你知道，来找我吧。但就像奥本海默，据我所知，你知道，他只是把经典物理学带到了最极端的断裂点，他说，如果有一个奇点，你把所有东西压缩成一个微小的原子会怎样？如果，你知道，有速度的终点会怎样？如果空间有终点会怎样？你知道，如果像有更多的重力，那么足够的重力能吸走光会怎样，然后说哦，它坏了，你知道，你不能有这些极端，所以一定有这种概率的二元论，有些事情还没有发生，所以我们不能完全计算它们，因为它们还没有发生，它们将会发生，它们正处于
of being discovered what they will be but they're not absolutes that we can calculate that's how he got to the mysticism of quantum physics and brought it to america from bore you know and even in psychology, the data of the talking cure, it was messy and it was anecdotal until Freud and Jung gave us the language of the unconscious and the archetype. You know, we were objectively right. Were they right in every detail? No, not really, but they gave us a lens, a framework, a story to see something, that once we saw, we couldn't unsee. And we need to get back to that. Numbers don't give you that. And that allowed us to navigate this chaos of the human mind, and they provided this map that allowed us to enter a territory.
被发现的过程中，它们会是什么，但它们不是我们可以计算的绝对值。这就是他如何达到量子物理学的神秘主义并将其从玻尔带到美国，你知道，即使在心理学中，谈话疗法的数据，它是混乱的，是轶事性的，直到弗洛伊德和荣格给了我们潜意识和原型的语言。你知道，我们客观上是对的。他们在每一个细节上都对吗？不，并不完全是，但他们给了我们一个镜头，一个框架，一个故事来看待某件事，一旦我们看到了，我们就无法再忽视它。我们需要回到那个状态。数字给不了你那个。这使我们能够驾驭人类心灵的这种混乱，他们提供了这张地图，使我们能够进入一个领土。
We've spent the last 50 years trying to strip the storytelling capacity ever since CBT, ever since the Reagan and Thatcher Revolution, you know, every since the insurance company, ever since the corporatization of colleges that are supposed to train people, we've stripped the storytelling capacity out of our profession in this misguided attempt to be taken seriously by the hard sciences or treated like one, which I don't think should be the goal of psychology at all.
我们花了过去50年的时间试图剥离讲故事的能力，自从CBT以来，自从里根和撒切尔革命以来，你知道，自从保险公司以来，自从本应培训人们的大学公司化以来，我们在这个试图被硬科学认真对待或被当作硬科学对待的误导性尝试中，剥离了我们行业中的讲故事能力，我认为这根本不应该是心理学的目标。
And in doing so, The brain is a story processing machine. Look up neuroscience like Michael Gazzaniga. Look up people like Carl Friston. The brain is trying to understand stories based on past data that will happen in the future. And where there's predictive metrics are wrong, it causes a problem until we understand the story that got the predictive mechanism there,
在这样做的时候，大脑是一台故事处理机器。查查神经科学，比如迈克尔·加扎尼加。查查像卡尔·弗里斯顿这样的人。大脑正在试图根据过去的数据理解未来会发生的故事。而在预测指标错误的地方，它会导致问题，直到我们理解了导致预测机制的故事，
pick the predictive mechanism apart, and then teach you to predict differently. You know, that would be Fristons. would be Fristons neuroscience work. You can read them out about them on the Get Therapy, Birmingham.com blog if you want. And, you know, Gazzaniga saw these kind of layers of conscious story and awareness that were competing. And those things, neuroscience, cognitive science,
把预测机制拆开，然后教你以不同的方式预测。你知道，那是弗里斯顿的。那是弗里斯顿的神经科学工作。如果你愿意，可以在Get Therapy, Birmingham.com博客上阅读关于他们的内容。而且，你知道，加扎尼加看到了这些相互竞争的意识故事和觉知的层面。而那些东西，神经科学，认知科学，
is more friendly to the idea, which is a harder degree to get, by the way, and a more respected one than social work or clinical psychology. they're more open to the idea that the brain is a storymaking system that has to be dealt with narratively because it prefers that structure and recreates it than clinical psychology. Just because of insecurity, just because we can't look at numbers that tell us that the way we've always done it is wrong. When we see the numbers tell us that story, we figure out another thing that they must mean because that can't. can't be true. Is that evidence-based? We have to be brave enough to look in the mirror again,
对这个想法更友好，顺便说一句，这是一个更难获得的学位，也比社会工作或临床心理学更受尊重。他们比临床心理学更开放地接受大脑是一个必须以叙事方式处理的故事制造系统，因为它更喜欢那种结构并重新创造它。仅仅因为不安全感，仅仅因为我们不能看告诉我们我们一直以来的做法是错误的数字。当我们看到数字告诉我们那个故事时，我们想出它们一定意味着的另一件事，因为那不可能是真的。那是循证的吗？我们必须足够勇敢地再次照镜子，
and we need to be brave enough to look at the data, whether it's the 2.7 recovery rate of the Star D, which when they were like, oh, the study's bad. Somebody messed up. Nobody published that and got it on the news, one, but two, nobody was like, hell, 2.7, that's really bad. That wasn't the story. The story was that the study that didn't show that was done badly, not the reality once we re-looked at the data of what it actually said. We didn't do anything with that. What's the story here? I mean, the path forward is not about choosing between science and narrative. It's about realizing that science is a narrative. It is the grandest and most complex and most rigorous story that we have ever tried to tell. And I don't want to attack it. I want to
我们需要足够勇敢地看数据，无论是Star D的2.7恢复率，当他们像，哦，研究很糟糕。有人搞砸了。没有人发表那个并让它上新闻，第一，但第二，没有人像，天哪，2.7，那真的很糟糕。那不是故事。故事是那个没有显示出这一点的研究做得不好，而不是我们重新审视数据后它实际所说的现实。我们没有用它做任何事。这里的故事是什么？我的意思是，前进的道路不是在科学和叙事之间做出选择。而是要意识到科学就是一种叙事。它是我们尝试讲述过的最宏大、最复杂、最严谨的故事。我不想攻击它。我想
help it tell its story better. Hey guys, thank you so much for listening. I really appreciate it. And it would be a huge service to me if you are interested in the market to check out Hardy vitamins. Gethardy.com is their website and use offer code taproot to check out. That's only if you need it. They do have some of the best randomized controlled trials in the business showing that their vitamins are able to help with ADHD and autism.
帮助它更好地讲述它的故事。嘿，伙计们，非常感谢你们的收听。我真的很感激。如果你对市场感兴趣，去看看Hardy维生素，那对我来说将是一个巨大的服务。Gethardy.com是他们的网站，结账时使用优惠码taproot。那只有在你需要的时候才用。他们确实拥有业内一些最好的随机对照试验，显示他们的维生素能够帮助治疗多动症和自闭症。
And we've also seen them help with dopamine disorders, but that's just coming from things that patients tell me. I didn't find Hardy through advertising or anything. I found it because I run a psychotherapy clinic and a whole lot of people told me they tried everything and that's what worked. And we had them on the podcast. There's one with them way back if you will listen to it.
我们也看到它们有助于多巴胺紊乱，但这只是来自病人告诉我的事情。我不是通过广告或任何东西找到Hardy的。我找到它是通过我经营一家心理治疗诊所，很多人告诉我他们尝试了一切，而那个有效。我们让他们上了播客。如果你愿意听的话，很久以前有一期关于他们的节目。
But we would appreciate it if you use offer code taproot and check out at hardy.com or gethardy.com. um they worked for me my wife was afraid that i was going to be alex jones and like selling vitamins on their radio uh and then she tried them and was like oh wow these are uh really helpful and i wasn't really expecting anything i actually didn't buy them i you know told them patients that they uh i patients told me that they worked i did the podcast with hardy and then hardy um i looked up their research after i heard about it from patients and then i um got a box of hardy in the mail and i took good because I take vitamins and it's like I kind of noticed a difference with these so
但如果你在hardy.com或gethardy.com结账时使用优惠码taproot，我们将不胜感激。嗯，它们对我有效，我妻子担心我会成为亚历克斯·琼斯，像在电台卖维生素一样，然后她尝试了它们，说，哦，哇，这些真的很有帮助，我并没有真正期待任何事情，我实际上没有买它们，我，你知道，告诉病人它们，病人告诉我它们有效，我做了关于Hardy的播客，然后Hardy，嗯，我在从病人那里听说后查了他们的研究，然后我，嗯，在邮件里收到了一盒Hardy，我吃了，因为我吃维生素，感觉这些确实有点不同，所以
I don't know if they work for me hopefully they work for you thank you for your time Thank you. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我不知道它们是否对我有效，希望它们对你有效，谢谢你的时间。谢谢。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。